le télescope web révolutionne
l'astronomie c'est la Une du Figaro
aujourd'hui bonjour à tous ces photos
ont été dévoilées hier par hasard et on
vous prévient c'est vertigineux pour en
parler aujourd'hui avec nous Cyril van
Helberg rédacteur en chef du service
science du Figaro bonjour Cyril bonjour
Vincent bonjour à tous les internautes
qui nous rejoignent pour notre émission
sciences J+1 tout au long de soleil
comme d'habitude vous n'hésitez pas à
poser vos questions on essaiera d'y
répondre au mieux et on va montrer un
peu toutes ces images ces images qui
sont magnifiques ces images qui ont été
dévoilées hier par ça commençait dans la
nuit on va tout regarder tout comprendre
essayer d'être le plus pédagogique
possible et c'est tout comprendre parce
que personnellement moi j'ai arrêté les
cours de physique assez tôt donc voilà
on va essayer de savoir un peu ce qu'on
voit sur ces photos pourquoi les
scientifiques parce que il y a ça j'ai
l'impression que les scientifiques là
ils voient il trouve que c'est
magnifique ce qu'on a découvert et ils
sont un peu il y avait une expression
dans le dans le papier du jour ils sont
comme devant un sapin de Noël oui oui
c'est ce que dit Didier prix Nobel 2019
que c'est
découvert les exoplanètes il a dit on
est aujourd'hui comme des comme des
enfants le jour de Noël et en fait tous
les astronomes qui ont parlé ils sont
hyper excités et d'abord en fait ils ont
ils ont la même choc esthétique que nous
quand ils voient ces images il trouve ça
magnifique et eux en plus et ben ils
arrivent à y voir de la science et donc
il voit le potentiel de découverte que
ça annonce en fait on a 4 images et ces
quatre images déjà elle nous dit que
dans des champs très très variés de
l'astronomie et ben ça va tout changer
il y aura un avant et un après le James
web c'est vraiment un télescope qui
ouvre des des potentiels incroyables
pour l'astronomie moderne et c'est pour
ça que les scientifiques sont hyper
excités et on va regarder ça les images
une à une je salue HW qui nous rejoint
un Jojo pero qui nous dit il n'y a
personne qui parle on vient de démarrer
c'est pour ça vous étiez sur l'écran
d'attente mais vous n'hésitez pas à
continuer à nous suivre et à poser vos
questions on va peut-être commencer par
la toute première photo celle qui a été
diffusée hier alors non elle était
diffusé lundi soir dans la nuit oui en
fait assez tard c'est c'est Joe Biden
donc le président aux États-Unis qui est
un peu court-circuité le plan de la NASA
et qui au dernier moment il a organisé
une conférence de presse à la Maison
Blanche pour présenter la première image
avec presque 24 heures d'avance sur le
plan de la NASA et cette première image
en fait c'est c'est un simple c'est plus
qu'un symbole c'est l'image la plus
profonde de l'univers qu'on n'est jamais
réalisé dans l'infrarouge
on va peut-être en parler mais
l'infrarouge c'est le télescope pas dans
le visible comme nous ils regardent des
longueurs d'onde un peu plus lointaines
qui sont au-delà du rouge donc on
appelle ça infrarouge et l'avantage de
l'infrarouge c'est que ça permet de
permettre de voir plus loin dans
l'univers des galaxies qui s'éloignent
des galaxies qui rougissent et on voit
sur cette image en fait il y a plein de
choses il y a c'est incroyable on
pourrait passer des heures à l'arrière
qu'elle a commenté enfin j'ai passé du
temps avec un spécialiste du du sujet
pour qu'il me justement il m'explique ce
qu'il faut regarder ce qu'il faut voir
ce qu'il faut comprendre
et tout et on voit plein de petites
tâches lumineuses et chacune des petites
tâches lumineuses sur cette image c'est
une galaxie
alors
c'est le plus important en fait une
galaxie c'est c'est un regroupement de
milliards d'étoiles nous on en connaît
une on est enfin le soleil fait partie
de la Voie Lactée donc c'est notre
galaxie la Voie Lactée c'est ce qu'on
voit là pendant les sièges les ciels
d'été quand le ciel est vraiment assez
pur on voit une grande panache blanc
dans le ciel et tout ça ça c'est des
milliards d'étoiles qui nous entourent
et qui forment un grand disque un grand
disque avec une spirale peut-être vu des
images de Galaxy que c'est classique
avec ses spirales qui s'enroulent il y
en a plein sur cette image
il y en a une bleue en haut à droite là
qui est une spirale assez bien détaillée
en fait et l'étoile notre soleil c'est
un des 100 milliards d'étoiles de notre
galaxie et là ce qu'on voit sur cette
une seule image on voit des milliers de
galaxies donc là si on zoome
deux de celle dans lequel nous on vit la
Voie Lactée
et donc notre Voie Lactée elle contient
100 milliards d'étoiles
celle là elle je sais pas combien j'ai
pas compté dans un capable de le dire
mais c'est au moins plusieurs milliards
et vous avez sur les autres petits
points lumineux sur l'image c'est pas
des artefacts c'est pas des des étoiles
ce sont eux aussi elles aussi des
galaxies très lointaines donc chacune de
ces galaxies rencontre enfin comporte
des milliards d'étoiles autour de chaque
étoile et au moins une planète je vous
laisse faire le décompte c'est juste
déjà on est dans voilà dans l'infini
c'est comme si là on essaie de pour se
dit la terre par rapport à ça qu'est-ce
que ça représente la terre par rapport à
ça c'est à rien du tout
c'est voilà notre Soleil la Terre elle
est déjà toute petite à côté du soleil
le soleil il est un des petits points
lumineux sur une galaxie qui était au
milliard de au milieu de milliards
ça donne le vertige
mais le plus intéressant sur cette image
en fait pourquoi pourquoi la NASA les
scientifiques ont visé ce coin du ciel
c'est pour une raison assez précise
c'est qu'il y a on voit au milieu au
centre on voit quelques quelques
galaxies qui sont plus brillantes qui
sont plus blanches
voilà celle-là il y en a d'autres aussi
en fait toutes les galaxies blanches
elles font partie de ce qu'on appelle un
amas de Galaxy c'est un regroupement de
galaxies qui sont reliés entre elles par
la gravitation donc elles sont elles
sont elles s'attirent les unes les
autres et elles restent ensemble dans un
grand voisinage
et c'est à moi il a une masse colossale
qui
qui fait un effet de lentilles alors là
on fait la physique un peu un peu
pointue un peu costaud parce que il faut
il faut appeler Einstein Einstein il
avait il avait expliqué que que la masse
était capable de courber la lumière et
donc et donc en fait la masse de cet
amas de Galaxy il est tellement elle est
tellement énorme qu'elle récit à courber
la lumière de galaxies encore plus
lointaine donc c'est à dire c'est à dire
quand on regarde ces galaxies la lumière
nous parvient pas directement ouais en
fait en fait la main il fait il fait il
fait comme une commune loupe ou comme
une Valentine un grand télescope une
grande longue vue il n'y rend visible au
premier plan des galaxies qui sont hyper
lointaines qui ont plus qui étaient qui
étaient qui ont émis leur lumière il y a
plus de 13 milliards d'années et donc
c'est les arcs lumineux qu'on voit sur
l'image c'est pas des défauts de l'image
on les voit César qui sont un peu rouge
et ce rouge il indique d'ailleurs que
c'est les galaxies qui sont lointaines
qui sont bien plus lointaines que celles
qui sont en blanc en premier plan et
donc ces arcs c'est la déformation par
l'attraction de la masse de cette année
qui
est en fait ça fait un effet de
lentilles les astronomes appelle ça une
anti gravitationnelle et ça permet de
voir des objets qui seraient même avec
le James web invisible en fait donc ça
amplifie leur lumière ça les met ça les
rapproche au premier plan mais ça les
déforme donc si on zoome un peu en
arrière sur cette image on verra qu'il y
a des dizaines des centaines d'Arc de
petit arcs rouges il y en a il y en
avait vraiment mais plein plein et
chacun de ces arcs c'est la lumière
d'une galaxie comme une spirale qu'on a
vu tout à l'heure mais qui a été déformé
et c'est des galaxies qu'on que qui sont
les plus lointaines parmi les plus
lointaines qu'on n'est jamais vus donc
et on parle qu'on parle lointaine voilà
on va arrêter de parler en kilomètres
parce que là on est plus là dedans on
est sur des années lumières et là ce
qu'on voit c'est à 13 milliards
d'années-lumière oui oui en fait le
[Musique]
une des une des galaxies une des très
déformés en rouge a été mesuré par le
par les scientifiques à 13,1
milliards d'années-lumière
en fait l'idée c'est que la vitesse de
la lumière elle se déplace hyper
lentement en fait c'est ça c'est quelque
chose on sait trois c'est juste 300000
km/s et donc juste nous le soleil qui
est lentement bien évidemment oui à
l'échelle univers c'est hyper lent le
soleil le soleil la lumière du soleil
mais 8 minutes pour ne pas venir
pour la lumière qui arrive de mars c'est
une demi-heure et donc là et pourtant
c'est les planètes qui sont hyper
proches la plus proche étoile du soleil
c'est 4 années-lumière donc c'est la
lumière mais quatre années pour ne pas
revenir là la lumière de ces galaxies
elle a mis 13 milliards d'années arrivé
jusqu'à nous et 13 milliards d'années
c'est pas très loin de l'âge de
l'univers
on le sait qu'il est autour de 13,8
milliards le Big de Big Bang le début de
tout ça c'est 13,8 milliards d'années
donc c'est les galaxies qui sont dans
les ce qu'on appelle les premiers âges
de l'univers c'est quelques centaines de
millions d'années après le Big Bang il y
a eu une première génération d'étoiles
des premières étoiles qui se rassemblent
qui se regroupent et sa forme les
premières galaxies et c'est ça qu'on
commence à voir avec le James web avec
juste cette première image qui est la
champ profond parce qu'on voit très loin
donc on voit dans le passé on voit très
loin enfin quand on regarde comme la
lumière énormément de temps nous
parvenir en fait ce qu'on regarde c'est
les étoiles des galaxies qui sont hyper
vieilles donc en fait on voit ces
galaxies un peu alors un peu avant le
big bang après après après le Big Bang
et imaginons que sur cette galaxie les
gens fassent la même chose que nous il
nous verrait aussi à une époque où il
n'y avait pas grand chose sur terre
alors là voilà bah il nous verrait pas
parce que notre notre étoile le Soleil
il a 4,5 milliards d'années
donc on a voilà on est on est arrivé 2/3
après le là de l'univers donc alors il y
avait une vidéo très intéressante que je
vais essayer de vous passer maintenant
c'est la vidéo qui est ici qui pour qui
est là pour montrer en fait ce qu'on
voit sur cette image oui parce que le
champ de vision de du télescope il est
incroyablement réduit donc ça c'est la
photo qu'on voit voilà on parle de ça et
on dézoom et on voit plein plein
d'étoiles
on voit des grosses étoiles proches donc
là qui sont accaparés sont rouges on
dézoome on dézoome et là on se rapproche
une galaxie proche et un coin de la Voie
lactée et là c'est quelque chose dans le
ciel qui fait
quelques quelques dizaines de degrés
dans le fond du ciel et pour voir la
zone du ciel qui a été pointée par le
télescope c'est comme si on tient une
aiguille à coudre une aiguille de où il
y a coudre au bout de la au bout du bras
et on regarde à travers le chat de la
l'aiguille et on regarde le champ de
l'aiguille c'est c'est la partie du ciel
qu'on voit donc on voit des milliers de
galaxies sur cette petite image qui
représente pourtant une partie mais
infime de tout le de tout le ciel donc
c'est c'est pour donner un coffret
encore cette idée de vertige enfin c'est
impossible de de pas se sentir minuscule
quand on voit ses toutes les dimensions
par rapport à ça
Joe COS qui nous dit on regarde une
photo qui a 13 milliards d'années c'est
amusant effectivement il va falloir pas
tous les éléments pas tous les éléments
la saison 4 milliards d'années les Mama
qui fait la lentille donc il fait cet
effet de loop gravitationnel lui il a 4
milliards d'années-lumière alors j'ai
une question de HW qui mais comment la
masse peut-elle être déformée la lumière
la masse fait que la gravité est
modifiée et donc les photons sont
attirés oui c'est ça c'est la
trajectoire des photons qui est qui est
attiré par la concentration de masse et
dans la culture populaire le l'effet le
plus extrême de ce phénomène c'est le
trou noir le trou noir c'est une
gravitation une attractionnellement
tellement forte que la lumière n'arrive
plus à en sortir et donc elle est piégée
au centre du trou noir et on ne voit
aucune lumière qui en sort et ça en fait
cet objet si particulier dans le cosmos
on en parlera aussi tout à l'heure parce
que je crois qu'on va réussir à trop
voir un bout de trou noir
qui nous dit donc il y a forcément
d'autres créatures il est impossible
qu'on soit seul ça c'est le côté vertige
aussi oui on est on est pas grand chose
et on pourrait se dire que avec tout ça
il y a bien il y a bien une autre
civilisation quelque part dans le coin
mais le problème c'est qu'il va falloir
réussir à rentrer en contact un jour ou
l'autre avec ouais contact ou même
détection enfin on va en parler un petit
peu plus tard mais ça fait aussi partie
des du des découvertes qu'on attend avec
le James web il va observer des planètes
des exoplanètes et
mesurer l'atmosphère qui les entoure
et notamment il y a un programme qui
hyper intéressant qui cherche à mesurer
des atmosphères autour de planète qui
sont rocheuses autour d'une petite
étoile des planètes qui sont assez
proches de la taille de la Terre et mais
ça on en parlera plus tard parce que
c'est vrai que c'est c'est pareil c'est
un espoir incroyable si on arrive à
détecter de l'eau ou des conditions une
atmosphère avec des conditions propices
à l'apparition de la vie
on se rapproche d'une fin d'une
compréhension pas de panique
compréhension mais des moments on va
peut-être voir des des planètes
habitables d'autres
qui c'est quand qu'il compte envoyer des
fusées capables d'aller très loin pour
voir s'il y a d'autres vies le problème
c'est que c'est c'est toujours compliqué
il y en a les limites de la physique qui
font rappeler parce que là on voit les
choses et on se dit tiens on voit des
choses donc on pourrait y aller on prend
des fusées très rapides mais c'est pas
si simple que ça non en fait on a dit
tout à l'heure la vitesse de la lumière
à l'échelle de l'univers elle est
incroyablement lente et pourtant pour
nous c'est une limite indépassable on
n'ira jamais plus vite que 300000 km par
seconde
et voilà et on m'a dit même à cette
vitesse là pour aller à l'étoile la plus
proche c'est 4 ans et on est incapable
de voyager aussi vite que la lumière
d'aujourd'hui on est on est à des
centièmes de la lumière donc on estime
que si on envoyait une sonde aujourd'hui
vers Alpha du Centaure c'est l'étoile la
plus proche la plus proche qu'il
faudrait entre 200 et 400 ans avant
qu'elle arrive
donc même et ça c'est juste les tours la
plus proche et quand on regarde là on
regarde des galaxies qui sont hyper
lointaines plusieurs milliards
d'années-lumière donc on ira on ira
peut-être un jour
près des toiles proches mais ça mettra
des plusieurs décennies enfin de
plusieurs générations on parle de
projets les choses de plus en général
sur donc on n'y est pas on est vraiment
pas près d'y aller voilà c'est pour
votre réponse vos Pedro ah je voulais
qu'il me dit incroyable c'est fascinant
merci un jour on me dira quelqu'un m'a
dit tu verras du 29 ils annonce mon
exemple d'extraterrestres je ne le
croyais pas mais je commence à prendre
espoir guillotine qui lui dit que c'est
fascinant et effrayant à la fois
selon vous Alain qui vient d'arriver je
pense qu'il est selon vous qui est
peut-il y avoir derrière ce qu'on voit
alors il y a une limite en fait le
télescope il va essayer de voir le plus
loin possible regardez le plus le plus
loin dans le passé pour se rapprocher
des Big Bang mais il y a quand même une
frontière indépassable c'est
on sait que 400 à peu près 400 000 ans
après le Big Bang enfin du Big Bang
jusqu'à 400000 ans l'univers est
totalement opaque il est tellement dent
il est rempli de d'hydrogène et d'hélium
et des atomes qui sont neutres et qui
laissent pas passer la lumière même si à
la lumière qui était mise elle est
absorbée par les par les par les atomes
et donc il y a aucune lumière l'univers
est opaque dans 400000 ans et au bout de
400000 ans les premières étoiles
commencent à exciter le milieu
et l'univers et le rendre transparent et
donc on verra jamais au-delà de 400 000
ans après le Big Bang
mais d'ailleurs il y a des télescopes
qui ont qui ont mesuré ce début de
rayonnement
alors Jojo Pedro qui on va faire une
transition parfaite qui nous dit
pourquoi on ne voit pas le trou noir
parce qu'il n'y en a pas sur cette photo
mais vous-même tout à l'heure que sur
celle-là celle qu'on était sur le début
alors attendez on va la montrer est-ce
qu'on peut déjà dire un peu ce qu'on
voit sur cette photo alors là ça c'est
le quintet de Stephen
parce qu'en fait il y a 5 galaxies
c'est fin c'était Edward Stefan c'est un
astronome français qui en 1878 je crois
à vue pour la première fois ce
regroupement de galaxies alors c'est pas
la vue la plus explicite on en a une
dans une autre couleur qui est qui
montre mieux la forme de ces galaxies et
en fait c'est des galaxies qui sont en
train de rentrer dedans qui sont en
collision donc il y a des interactions
incroyables avec elle elles sont en
train de tourner autour et de se
perturber et on voit sur celle qui est
en haut l'image avec il y a un lien un
point lumineux très fort enfin plus
brillant que les autres c'est pas une
étoile c'est l'activité provoquée par un
trou noir au centre de cette galaxie et
donc c'est en fait c'est là c'est c'est
une découverte
du James web c'est un instrument qui a
été conçu on peut faire cocorico parce
que c'est un astronome français qui a
qui a poussé pour cet instrument soit
installé sur le James web
les Américains disaient non c'est trop
compliqué on sait pas faire il faut le
refroidir les températures trop froides
instrument est là et aujourd'hui ça
fonctionne manière de manière magnifique
et donc on voit on voit ce trou noir qui
est qui est actif et on fait on voit pas
le trou noir on a dit tout à l'heure on
coupe la lumière il n'empêche de sortir
donc on voit pas le trou noir lui-même
et on voit la matière qui qui tourne
autour et qui est accéléré et qui chute
à l'intérieur et avant le moment de
tomber l'accélération est telle que ça
produit des rayonnements assez assez
fort et à très énergétique et c'est ce
qu'on voit là dans l'infrarouge alors on
a beaucoup beaucoup de questions on va
essayer de vous répondre à tous déjà
guillotine les personnes qui apprécient
la vidéo n'oubliez pas de liker pouces
bleus effectivement abonnez-vous aussi
sur notre page Youtube n'hésitez pas
pour voir d'autres live science comme
celui-là on en fait souvent
Alain qui nous demande est-ce que tout
cela se rapproche ou s'éloigne
alors il y a de manière générale les
galaxies quand on regarde les galaxies
un peu au hasard dans l'univers on a
l'impression que la majorité d'entre
elles s'éloigne et en fait c'est pas
parce que parce que c'est en fait c'est
la
c'est un effet qui qui prouve que
l'univers est en expansion donc ça
c'était une découverte importante du
début du 20e siècle c'est comprendre que
que l'univers n'est pas figé n'est pas
stable n'est pas statique mais il est en
expansion continue et les galaxies
s'éloignent les unes des autres
vous allez me dire mais dans un univers
infini et comment comment on peut être
en expansion
là je fais appel à une image que que
proposait
uberive l'astronome canadien qui est
écrivait en fait il faut s'imaginer un
pudding lui les Canadiens donc il parle
de pudding plus que de gâteaux mais une
patte à gâteau qu'on met dans combien
dans un four avec des pépites de
chocolat quand le gars quand le gâteau
gonfle le gâteau cuit ça gonfle et ça
s'étend et les pépites du chocolat à
l'intérieur du pudding et bien en fait
elle s'éloigne les unes des autres donc
les galaxies dans l'Univers aujourd'hui
c'est comme un gâteau qui est en train
de monter qui est en train de cuire et
de souffler parce qu'il y a de plus en
plus il y a de plus en plus de vide qui
écarte les objets entre eux en fait on
peut dire ça exactement donc on est en
train c'est l'univers les composants de
l'univers c'est loin les uns les autres
et donc la majorité des galaxies
s'éloigne alors on a Alain qui nous
demande comment est-ce que c'est
toujours la grande question parce que là
on a on a découvert combien de galaxies
grâce à ça est-ce qu'on sait combien de
sur l'image j'ai pas compté mais il y en
a il y en a littéralement des milliers
[Musique]
chaque point lumineux de la sur cette
image là c'est une galaxie à part il y a
quand même une vous êtes remarqué qu'il
y a des points lumineux qui sont
entourés par des étoiles à 6 branches là
en fait ce qu'on appelle les aigrettes
en fait c'est des artefacts de du
télescope c'est la forme des miroirs qui
sont hexagonaux qui créent ces formes de
diffraction et ça c'est les étoiles qui
sont proches qui sont dans la Voie
Lactée d'accord donc les choses les plus
visibles et les plus alors peut-être pas
le plus beau mais les choses les plus
visibles facilement sur les choses les
moins intéressantes sur cette photo au
final et c'est les choses que les que
les astronomes vont essayer d'effacer
c'est c'est grandes ces grandes formes
assez branches là les aigrettes il y a
du boulot pour les effacer essayer de
voir s'il y a pas des informations
cachées derrière des galaxies qui qui
s'y cache alors je vais continuer sur la
question d'Alain parce que il me demande
il m'a pas demandé combien d'années il
m'a demandé comment on va les nommer
toutes ces galaxies aucune chance qu'on
les nomme toutes
aucune chance alors il y en a une il y
en a une qui est très déformée qui est
orange sur le voilà celle là elle a déjà
un surnom sur sur Internet
français qui l'a surnommé la galaxie du
béret et je vous laisse deviner pourquoi
mais en fait ça c'est une galaxie qui
est hyper lointaine et qui a été
déformée par la par les fêtes de l'anti
gravitationnelle mais on voit ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est qu'on voit sa
structure c'est-à-dire qu'on voit on
voit la forme on voit que c'est une
forme en spirale qui a été déformée et
ça c'est c'est que James web qui le rend
possible ce genre de vision c'est
extraordinaire on a d'autres questions
HW qui lui dit mais si les Galaxy
s'éloignent infiniment les unes des
autres qu'y a-t-il au centre
alors il y a pas de centre
parce que
dès la création de LBD juste après le
Big Bang et l'univers il est déjà infini
et il a il a pas de limite il a pas de
centre
c'est pas c'est pas une notion avec
laquelle nos esprits sont facilement
capables d'appréhender mais j'ai au
centre en tout cas on est géocentré
l'idée sans de l'univers en fait n'a pas
ça pas vraiment de sens
ou alors pour pouvoir approcher le
problème différemment
il peut pas y avoir de centre d'un
espace infini enfin le puisque il a pas
il se déplace tout le temps il a pas de
limite il a pas de limite parce que de
toute façon au delà l'univers
bah il y a pas il y a pas de matière il
y a pas d'espace-temps donc ça n'a pas
de sens non plus de dire au-delà de
l'univers enfin Gabriel me demande
justement dans quoi l'univers s'est-il
bah il s'étend il s'étend lui-même mais
il ne s'étend pas dans quelque chose
parce que si c'est notre site si c'est
tombé dans quelque chose ça veut dire
que il y a quelque chose et en fait non
il y a rien enfin il y a pas de il y a
pas d'espace il y a pas de temps
ça c'est
je je fais juste que rapporter des
choses que je ne comprends pas je joue
aussi mal à l'aise que vous pour avec
ces notions d'infini et de
oui mais un moment il faut il faut juste
les accepter enfin c'est parce que dans
le monde scientifique voilà c'est
quelque chose dans le monde scientifique
on rappelle que la science n'explique
pas forcément tout non et c'est va se
retrouver c'était pas son but mais
c'était de comprendre ce qui se passe et
surtout dans nos notre esprit est pas
forcément capable de d'appréhender
d'appréhender c'est une océans c'est de
la même manière que à l'idée avant le
big bang c'est pas quelque chose qui
c'est pas une question qui a un sens en
fait parce que avant le big bang il n'y
a pas il y a pas d'espace il y a pas de
temps donc bon donc du coup la question
de la W qui demande est-ce que ça
s'étend dans une direction en
particulier dans toutes les directions
dans toutes les directions il y a pas de
direction on peut dire ça
on a demandé le nom de l'instrument
français sur le télescope c'est Miri
alors Miri c'est Made in frared
j'ai oublié et en fait l'idée l'idée du
télescope dès le début c'était de
regarder dans l'infrarouge on en a déjà
un petit peu parlé pourquoi l'infrarouge
parce que l'infrarouge ça permet de
regarder plus loin des galaxies qui sont
qui s'éloignent justement et qui sont
rougis voilà dans la lumière est rougit
on le voit sur cette image toutes les
images les plus antennes elles sont
rouge orange
donc ça c'est le but de départ mais
l'inconvénient du de l'infrarouge c'est
qu'il faut que les détecteurs soient
hyper froids
et c'est pour ça que le je sais pas si
vous avez déjà vu la tête du télescope
mais il a un énorme bouclier thermique
avec plusieurs couches de films dorés
qui font la taille d'un cours de tennis
et qui servent à garder au froid les
instruments les détecteurs et en fait la
difficulté que proposait l'instrument
Miri c'est qu'il fallait le refroidir de
manière active c'est-à-dire qu'il
fallait qu'il y a une pompe cryogénique
pour refroidir encore plus encore plus
froid cet instrument à quelques degrés
du au-dessus du zéro absolu et la NASA
pensait que ça allait être trop
compliqué trop complexe et en fait c'est
astronome français bien lieu Lagache et
ben il a il a il a il a convaincu avec
un décompte des collègues américains
qu'il y avait un énorme intérêt à aller
plus loin dans l'infrarouge donc ce
qu'on appelle l'infrarouge moyen
c'était l'image qu'on a vu des des
squelettes des galaxies avec le trou
noir tout à l'heure c'est l'infrarouge
moyen
c'est on voit on voit plus la structure
on voit plus les étoiles mais on voit
les plutôt les nuages de poussière au
fond des galaxies et il y a un intérêt
aussi pour cette infrarouge moyen c'est
très intéressant pour aller voir encore
plus loin dans les premiers âges de
l'univers et c'est aussi pour faire la
spectroscopie des planètes analyser la
composition des planètes la l'infrarouge
moyen un intérêt énorme donc ça c'est un
peu une fierté
française c'est grâce à un français
qu'on a ces images là il est pas seul il
est passé
une partie de l'instrument une partie du
cœur de l'instrument a été construite à
Saclay au CE1 alors on va continuer sur
les questions un peu
vertigineuses on va dire est-ce que
notre univers peut en croiser à notre
c'est notre Big Bang a lieu autre part
alors là je l'appareil je sais pas si
c'est un sens de parler d'un autre
univers je sais qu'on parle les metaves
ou des univers qui pourraient être les
uns à côté les autres et ou enchasser
mais je c'est compliqué aucune idée
là-dessus totalement incompétent Alain
qui nous demande James est-il conçu pour
capter ou transmettre des sons ou des
résonances non pas de son c'est vraiment
un
détecteur de lumière des lumières
infrarouges parce que c'est ça aussi il
faut est-ce que c'est comme un télescope
où on va regarder dans une lunette
est-ce que
c'est on voit comme dans un comme dans
des lunettes ou comme dans une alors il
voit pas comme nous parce qu'il voit pas
dans le visible donc il voit pas
si regarde le soleil il va pas le voir
la même manière que nous quand il
regarde Jupiter il voit pas il voit pas
les mêmes couleurs que nous il voit pas
les mêmes longueurs d'onde mais mais
c'est un télescope qui fonctionne avec
les mêmes règles qu'un télescope optique
qui nous permet de voir le visible c'est
à dire qu'il y a un miroir qui est
concentre les rayons lumineux et qui les
envoie
vers des détecteurs qui ont eux vont
l'enregistrer mais la plus fine possible
et il y a plusieurs détecteurs donc il y
a dont celui dont on a parlé le Miri
pour le l'infrarouge un peu plus
longtemps le risque qu'il nous demande
est-ce qu'il serait assez puissant pour
zoomer sur une zone précise d'Andromède
de sorte à ce que les étoiles d'une
branche choisie soit visible et
détaillées alors il y a clairement le
potentiel pour ça Andromède c'est pour
ceux qui connaissent pas c'est une des
galaxies qui est visible à l'oeil nu
dans le ciel qu'elle est tellement
immense donc facile on peut dire facile
à l'ONU c'est une tâche floue il faut
avoir déjà des bons vieux il y a une nu
très noire mais ça paraît comme une
tache floue
les plus belles images avec un télescope
ça fait vraiment une très belle galaxie
spirale elle est à quelques millions
d'années-lumière donc elle est pas très
loin
et oui oui clairement
je ne soit pas le potentiel pour aller
sonder la structure des bras la
structure fine voir les étoiles dans
Andromède et on a une question Gabriel
on a parlé au début de ce live mais
pouvez-vous expliquer simplement
pourquoi nous venions des étoiles telles
qu'elles étaient il y a des milliers
d'années
en fait l'idée c'est que
la lumière voyage lentement et donc
quand on quand on regarde un objet
on le regarde tel qu'il était au moment
où il a émis la lumière donc c'est la
lumière a mis
l'étoile la plus proche et la 4
années-lumière donc la lumière quand on
regarde cette étoile on la regarde telle
qu'elle était il y a 4 ans donc si le
soleil s'éteignait par exemple on le
verrait que quatre ans après quatre ans
après si on était sur Alpha du Centaure
d'accord et donc si on regarde une
étoile qui est plus qui est plus
lointaine à 100 en année lumière on la
voit en fait telle qu'elle était
et ben il y a 100 ans
donc si on regarde une planète autour de
je sais pas quelques planètes autour de
son année lumière mais on la verrait
telle qu'il y a encore son voyage dans
le passé et quand on regarde des voilà
encore plus loin à des milliards
d'années on se rapproche du Big Bang on
se rapproche de début de l'univers donc
on voit des galaxies qui sont et des
étoiles plus anciennes alors c'est
physiquement impossible mais si ça veut
dire que si on se téléporter
actuellement à 13 milliards
d'années-lumière sur la galaxie qu'on a
vu tout à l'heure et qu'on regarde la
terre
très précisément on la verrait telle
qu'elle était à 13 milliards d'années
aussi donc on la verrait pas
effectivement c'est bien j'avais oublié
de suivre ce moment alors qu'il me
demande si nos livres d'astronomie
sont-ils en face d'être obsolètes
pour certaines dépenses internes
découvertes oui oui enfin le
révolution oui c'est une révolution
enfin c'est
on l'a vu sur la première image celle
avec les Galaxy la lointaine le Graal de
l'astronomie moderne c'est de voir et
d'observer la première génération de
l'étoile c'est la première les premières
étoiles qui se forment après le Big Bang
et c'est hyper intéressant parce que
c'est les étoiles qui sont formés avec
juste avec les éléments créés par le Big
Bang Big Bang il forme hydrogène hélium
et un peu de lithium donc des éléments
très légers et avec ces éléments là il a
fallu construire les premières étoiles
le problème c'est que nous on n'a pas
trop de modèles qui arrivent à les
former ces étoiles alors on sait
qu'elles existent parce qu'elles on est
le résultat de plusieurs générations
donc les premières générations d'étoiles
et l'élément légers c'est les étoiles
qui sont massives énormes en imagine
très lumineuse mais qui ont une durée de
vie très courte une étoile plus les
grosses puis elle brûle vite son
carburant dans quel moindre dure
longtemps donc c'est l'étoile qui dure
quelques millions d'années et qui en fin
de vie elles ont produit en fait par la
réaction de réactions nucléaire dans
leur cœur des éléments plus lourds
et si elles explosent en fin de vie
elles produisent alors à ce moment-là
encore des éléments plus lourds des
atomes le faire le
carbone qui vont enrichir les
générations suivantes donc nous on a
notre soleil il est composé de
d'hydrogène et d'hélium mais aussi
beaucoup d'éléments lourds qui sont et
issus d'une autre étoile précédemment
qui sont
issus de la mort d'étoiles précédentes
donc il y a des générations d'étoiles
comme ça et on cherche à voir la
première génération et donc le James web
s'il arrive à faire ça ça va être une
vraie révolution dans la compréhension
de la formation de l'univers et de c'est
voilà ces premières étoiles est-ce que
c'est ça qu'on voit sur ces images alors
qu'est-ce qu'on voit sur ces là en fait
on s'est beaucoup rapproché
et on voit
une étoile mourante dans notre propre
galaxie d'accord donc là on est sur
notre galaxie et on est sur le soleil
qui est en on est au centre là au centre
on a une étoile qui brille encore
et en fait c'est pas celle qui est morte
et on est on est à 2000 années-lumière
de la Terre donc on n'est pas très loin
on est vraiment dans la Voie Lactée on a
parlé tout à l'heure notre galaxie
on est dans assez proche un bras qui est
un des bras la spirale qui est tout près
tout proche de nous et ce qu'on voit
c'est les nuages de gaz et de poussière
qui sont émis quand l'étoile est morte
et là elle a
éjecté une grande quantité de matière il
reste de la chaleur au centre qui qui
continue à l'activer à la galaxie donc
c'est la lueur bleu qu'on voit au centre
c'est cette bulle de gaz qui a été
chauffée et qui est en fait qu'un
expansion et on voit le truc incroyable
avec le James web c'est qu'on voit dans
la dans la zone un peu brune marron
autour on voit des lobes je sais pas si
vous voyez on voit des structures avec
des vides qu'est-ce qu'on appelle des
lobes c'est
des poches en fait des poches plus ou
moins plus ou moins villes voilà est-ce
que c'est ça
en fait c'est
les endroits dans laquelle il y avait
plus ou moins de gaz et la lumière
arrive à chauffer et à passer au là donc
on voit en fait les irrégularités dans
la coquille de gaz dans la qui était
éjectée par la par l'étoile
et sur le il y a donc ça c'est la
première vue qui est
l'infrarouge proche et à droite c'est la
vue par Miry donc l'instrument en
infrarouge un peu plus lointain et on
voit au centre qu'est-ce qu'on voyait
deux étoiles deux étoiles et en fait on
voit l'étoile mourante en rouge c'est
celle qui est éjecté tout cette quantité
de gaz et de poussière et son compagnon
qui est une toile qui elle qui est pas
encore en fin de vie et si elle meurt
elle fera une deuxième coquille qui va
faire une coquille double donc c'est on
est en train de voir la les conséquences
de la mort d'une étoile mais on est on
est là dans la c'est le voisin de la
terre et c'est
et c'est extraordinaire parce que c'est
ce déplacement du nuage de gaz dans le
milieu interstellaire pas il intéresse
énormément les les astrophysiciens parce
que c'est on sait que c'est comme ça
aussi que que les étoiles en fin de vie
elles ont semence le milieu autour
d'elle pour créer après des générations
d'étoiles plus et des systèmes
planétaires parce que quand il y a une
étoile qui se forme aujourd'hui et là
entouré d'un nuage de gaz et de
poussière nous ça c'est l'intérêt parce
que c'est ça que c'est ça qui forme les
planètes et donc la terre elle est issue
d'un nuage de gaz et de et d'éléments un
peu plus lourd sinon on n'a pas de on
est un peu comme sur deux alors on va on
va voilà mais est-ce que c'est comme si
on était sur des plantes qui mouraient
et qui en faisaient
grâce à leur semence
c'est exactement ça et c'est et pour ça
qu'on parle de génération c'est vraiment
des
c'est c'est la vie et la mort d'une
étoile qui permet à des générations
suivantes de s'enrichir d'éléments
nouveaux donc c'est c'est oui c'est un
enchaînement et c'est
presque c'est on n'est pas loin d'un
processus biologique enfin pas
biologique parce que il y a pas de
contrôlé mais c'est voilà c'est c'est
une bonne analogie est-ce que on a une
question d'Alain qui demande est-ce que
James web pourrait se retourner pour
faire un selfie de notre amas de galaxie
et comme ça on peut dire un peu où
est-ce que James web actuellement par
rapport à nous alors Jameson il a pas
fait il peut pas vraiment se retourner
enfin il peut pointer dans toutes les
directions du ciel il est il est loin de
la terre il est 1,5 millions de
kilomètres il est sur une orbite
assez lointaine qu'on a un point qu'on
appelle le point de Lagrange et un des
points d'équilibre autour du Soleil
entre la terre et le soleil et donc il y
a pas de
[Musique]
il n'y a pas de zone de fiel qui ne
puisse pas regarder
voilà mais
il peut il peut regarder loin et là on
est l'image qu'on a vu les images
précédentes d'essai aux États-Unis avant
le lancement et on voit en bas le
bouclier en jaune c'est les miroirs du
télescope donc ils sont recouverts de
très fines couches d'or ils sont
hexagonaux parce qu'on sait pas faire un
miroir d'une seule forme de 6m50 de
manière très légère en plus il était
replié pour que ça rentre sous la coiffe
de la fusée Ariane 5 et ces tests ça a
été la partie la plus longue de la
mission en fait ça a été ça a duré des
années et des années le télescope il
avait fini de construire en 2016 lancé
25 décembre 2021 et entre temps mais ils
ont tout testé pour être sûr que ça
marche en fait c'était une telle
complexité enfin c'est et c'est ça qui a
augmenté le coût et qui l'a rendu aussi
cher ça coûte
11 milliards de dollars là on voit les
films et les différentes couches du
bouclier thermique qui protègent donc
qui permet de télescope de rester hyper
froid oui parce que ce
miroir déployé il y avait un ancien
alors un ancien télescope on peut dire
c'est le télescope
Hubble alors on va vous montrer cette
image voilà je vais vous montrer cette
image donc ça c'est l'image qu'on a
actuellement qui a été prise récemment
et ça c'est celle de Hubble il me semble
oui
alors est-ce que c'est le maintenant
c'est pas le même champ alors peut-être
c'est pas le même champ mais c'était
c'était un des champs profond de Hubble
sans sans lentilles gravitationnelle
mais en fait
[Musique]
quand on regarde l'image l'image
précédente avec
[Musique]
non parce qu'il est infini donc
pas mesurer l'infini mais
alors j'avais une autre photo parce que
on a vu cette image on va voir celle-là
on va montrer une autre alors c'est
celle qui faisait la Une du Figaro
aujourd'hui c'est je pense que c'est
l'une des plus jolies ouais c'est la
plus c'est vraiment la plus belle c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on voit sur cette image on
a l'impression de voir une montagne un
ciel étoilée de la poussière alors là on
est on est encore une fois dans le dans
le voisinage de du système solaire on
n'est pas très loin c'est à dire qu'on
est on est encore dans la galaxie et on
voit une pouponnière d'étoiles
cette masse brune rangée en fait c'est
des nuages de gaz et des poussières dans
lesquels naissent des milliers d'étoiles
et en fait c'est c'est on l'a dit tout à
l'heure c'est les étoiles en fin de vie
elles meurt et les échecs des gaz de la
gaz et de la poussière qui vont à leur
tour en semencer les générations
suivantes des toilettes et là on est
dans une région une région de la Voie
Lactée de nos galaxies ou il y a plus de
gaz et plus de poussière qu'ailleurs et
c'est une zone où les où il y a vraiment
une forte activité qui prématte qui
permet la naissance des toiles
c'est une région qui avait déjà été pris
en photo par Hubble ça avait fait ça
fait partie des photos un peu iconiques
de belles avec ce genre de paysage c'est
vrai très très et là l'immense nouveauté
donc c'est les détails la finesse de
détails qu'on arrive à avoir dans ces
nuages de gaz on a on arrive grâce à
l'infrarouge
à déterminer la structure à voir les
c'est comme si avant on voyait un peu on
voyait le profil de la montagne on
voyait avec Hubble on voyait le contour
de la montagne on va le montrer en même
temps parce que alors il y a un
chercheur il y a gadec qui en parle
beaucoup sur Twitter on vous conseille
d'ailleurs son compte Twitter donc ça
c'est l'image qu'on a aujourd'hui
et ça c'est l'image d'avant voilà et en
fait on voyait le contour mais on voyait
aucun détail dans la dans la région qui
nous intéresse c'est la région avec de
poussière qui est en bas de l'image et
donc et donc là on voit tout de suite le
gain de l'infrarouge qui permet de qui
fait un peu comme une échographie de lui
il est
il est il est
les capteurs pour schématiser sont plus
sensibles à la poussière qu'au gaz donc
avec Hubble en gros on voyait le bouton
le gaz et avec avec le James web on voit
la poussière et là on voit des
structures qui sont d'une finesse
incroyable qui sont d'une complexité si
on zoome un petit peu dans la partie
brune là n'importe où c'est on va le
faire mais sur notre image notre image
comme ça on pourra on se rend compte en
fait on a on a un niveau de détail qui
est mais juste hallucinant on voit les
les
zones de vie les zones plus riches en
gaz les on voit les petits points
lumineux là c'est les étoiles qui sont
qui sont jeunes qui sont en train de
naître et qui sont c'est fou de pouvoir
autant zoomer alors moi c'est ce que je
me suis dit quand j'ai téléchargé ces
images pour préparer ce live on a des
images d'une définition incroyable sur
des objets qui sont extrêmement loin et
ça c'est ça c'est rendu possible par la
par plusieurs choses la première c'est
évidemment la taille quand on a un grand
miroir on collecte plus de plus de
lumière et on arrive à voir des détails
plus fins donc ça c'est la résolution et
les autres choses c'est qu'il est dans
le télescope qui est dans un
environnement hyper stable donc il est
loin de l'attraction terrestre il a un
million et demi de kilomètres il est ce
qui fait que ça a été un peu la surprise
pour les astronomes il est le point son
pointage et extrêmement précis et stable
donc l'image n'a pas de bouger donc la
qualité est incroyablement nette combien
il faut de temps de pause pour une photo
comme ça j'ai pas le j'ai pas le le ton
exact pour celle là mais pour celle où
on voyait la galaxie lointaine c'était
12h d'accord pendant 12 heures c'est
comme vous quand vous avez votre
téléphone pour les non initiés comme
vous prenez votre téléphone vous appuyez
sur le bouton ça prend la photo là on
doit appuie sur le bouton on entend 12
heures non en fait c'est un peu plus
compliqué on a on paye plusieurs on met
les filtres successifs devant le capteur
et on fait deux heures par filtre il y
avait 6 filtres je crois sur son image
donc et après on est superposés
les différentes couleurs les différentes
longueurs d'onde effectivement mais
c'est ça l'idée et là je pense que c'est
aussi une pause de quelques de l'ordre
de la dizaine d'heures j'ai plus le
chiffre exact mais donc ça c'est des
étoiles qui qui en bas en bas les points
bleus là lumineux c'est les étoiles qui
sont des jeunes très jeunes étoiles qui
naissent dans cette pouponnière dans
cette région donnée qui tank en train de
créer plein d'étoiles
et quand on dit jeune parce que
justement on avait jeune c'est quelques
millions d'années voilà on a une alors
on a une question de
ces jeux là tout est relatif à ton sujet
bien évidemment
Ulric me demandait est-ce que on
pourrait voir des des
galaxies ou des étoiles qui n'ont que
quelques millions d'années ou leur
lumière ne nous est pas encore parvenu
alors la lumière
quelques millions d'années c'est un âge
assez courant pour pas mal d'étoiles on
a dit les les étoiles les plus gros sont
des durées courtes donc quand on voit
une étoile qui est très grosse très
massive on sait qu'elle a forcément
moins de allez 100 millions d'années
donc elle est donc elle est jeune en
revanche une petite étoile plus petite
que le soleil brune qui met peu de
lumière elle ça se trouve elle peut
avoir mais des plus de 10 milliards
d'années et parce que les brûlera son
carburant beaucoup plus lentement
effectivement donc on a vu ces images on
avait des questions alors je vais
essayer de la retrouver une question
exoplanète une atmosphère similaire à la
terre autour par exemple de l'étoile
Kepler vu qu'on a pu étudier atmosphère
de West 96B alors je sais pas si c'est
celle-là ouais
alors là comme ça c'est moins incroyable
c'est moins impressionnant ça semble un
peu plus ergoneux mais est-ce qu'on peut
essayer de comprendre un peu ce qu'on
voit ici oui en fait le
c'est en fait c'est marrant nous nous on
s'extasy sur la beauté des images les
scientifiques devant ça je schématise
mais c'est un peu c'est un peu vrai en
fait ce qui intéresse les scientifiques
c'est la décomposition de la lumière
avec les différentes longueurs d'onde
donc ce qu'on appelle un spectre
lumineux comme quand on fait passer la
lumière du soleil dans un prisme ça fait
un arc-en-ciel donc ça décompose la
lumière dans tous ses composantes toutes
ces lumières ces couleurs différentes et
ben on a le télescope il fait ça dans
l'infrarouge avec une finesse incroyable
et là c'est on a analysé la lumière qui
passe qui vient d'une étoile qui est à
mille années-lumière et qui traverse
l'atmosphère d'une étoile qui passe
devant
non non d'une planète donc il faut
imaginer une étoile de type solaire
comme le soleil
avec une planète qui passe devant et qui
rentre dans la ligne de visée entre
entre nous et l'étoile et donc la
lumière qui traverse l'atmosphère de
cette étoile on l'analyse avec le James
web et qu'est-ce qu'on voit on voyait
des pics et des bosses et des creux et
en fait pour les scientifiques c'est
quelque chose de très parlant et on voit
notamment la signature de l'eau donc il
y a de la planète donc il y a de l'eau
dans l'atmosphère de cette planète
on sait aussi qu'il y a des nuages parce
que il y a parce que dans certaines
longueurs d'onde l'amplitude du signal
qu'on attend de la de l'eau elle est un
petit peu atténuée donc elle est
absorbée par des nuages donc c'est une
planète qui est chaude parce qu'elle est
proche de son étoile
elle est gazeuse et son atmosphère
contient de l'eau donc déjà c'est on en
parle comme une Jupiter chaude c'est ça
oui c'est une Jupiter chaude elle est
elle fait la moitié de la masse de
Jupiter donc Jupiter c'est quand même la
plus grosse planète de notre système
solaire c'est 300 fois la masse de la
Terre donc là j'imagine qu'on est autour
de 150 fois la masse de la Terre
et pour faciliter l'observation en fait
c'est une on a pris un chemin étoile qui
passe hyper proche de son étoile elle
est elle fait le tour de son étoile en
trois jours et demi donc c'est une
révolution c'est trois jours et demi
dans tous les trois jours et demi elle
passe devant l'étoile et on peut
regarder une occultation un tronc on
appelle ça un transit en astronomie et
mesurer la composition et ce qui est là
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est qu'en
fait le spectre il a été fait il y a
trois jours une pause directe le spectre
est arrivé il y a presque pas de
traitement pour arriver à ce résultat là
et voir la signature de l'eau donc en
fait c'est
on sait que l'instrument ne fonctionne
parfaitement et maintenant le défi c'est
d'aller faire ce type d'analyse sur les
planètes qui nous intéressent plus des
planètes rocheuses oui parce qu'il
ressemble un peu plus à la terre plein
de gazeuse on peut mettre le pied dessus
c'est juste une boule de gaz c'est ma
grande majorité d'hydrogène et c'est
comme Jupiter Saturne Neptune
Uranus et il y a pas de surface donc
c'est une boule de gaz qui est trop
petite pour ce pour pour s'allumer en
étoile donc
pour répondre à certaines questions on
ne pourra pas y vivre en tout cas non
celle-là non mais mais on a on a une
détection enfin qui a pour arriver à
jour de résultats avant avec Hubble avec
les autres télescopes spatiaux dans
l'infrarouge qui s'appelait pizza
c'était des parfois des semaines de
pause et vérification là c'est
une pause un spectre instantané une
qualité incroyable donc vraiment et il y
a un programme d'observation qui
qui est porté aussi sur lequel travaille
les astronomes français
qui va visiter un système qui s'appelle
un système planétaire qui s'appelle
trappiste
il s'appelle trappiste parce qu'il était
découvert par des astronomes belges
qui pensent qu'il aime bien la bière et
ce système il a une grande particularité
c'est qu'il a il est il abrite cette
planète qui sont toutes rocheuses donc
certains d'une proche taille proche de
la Terre et qui tourne autour d'une
étoile assez assez petite et pas trop
loin de la Terre donc c'est 40
années-lumière donc c'est donc ça va
faire une cible pour le James web de
premier choix je crois qu'il y a déjà
200 heures d'observation qui sont prévus
pour observer toutes les planètes de ce
système et essayer de détecter des
traces de l'atmosphère parce que une
plainte rocheuse on n'est pas sûr qu'il
atmosphère oui mais on regarde nept on
regarde dans le système solaire mercure
va être rocheuse mais elle est trop
proche de son soleil et elle a pas
d'atmosphère
donc on va essayer de voir l'atmosphère
et sa composition de ces planètes là et
comment comment trouver effectivement
ces planètes là n'hésitez pas à poser
vos questions on va pas tarder à arrêter
quand même puisque ça fait bientôt 1h
qu'on est en direct
ce télescope Hubble télescope bubble
pardon excusez-moi télescope qui a été
lancé du coup fin décembre oui il va
continuer sa mission pendant combien de
temps alors en fait il avait il avait
une mission nominale donc c'était la
durée minimale pour laquelle a été
conçue c'était 5 ans
après là en fait le lancement par Ariane
5 donc c'était le 25 décembre en Guyane
l'a mis sur une position et une vitesse
tellement parfaite par rapport à ce qui
était prévu
qu'on sait que il a gagné à ce moment-là
le double ça sera au moins 10 ans et
après la mise à poste donc c'est la
manière la manœuvre du télescope pour le
mettre à son orbite finale 1,5 km pareil
à consommer très peu de carburant
de manière parfaite et donc là encore on
gagne au moins 50 donc on parle parce
que le
la limite c'est en fait c'est le
carburant dont on a besoin pour le
pointer et pour le garder toujours avec
le bouclier vers le soleil pour pas
qu'il chauffe et tout ça ça il y a des
il y a plein de petits moteurs
avec du carburant et c'est ça qui est
c'est entre autres ça qui détermine la
durée de vie s'il y a une panne aussi
tout s'arrêter mais pour le moment tout
fonctionne parfaitement donc au moins 15
ans on devrait
combien il a coûté quand même 11
milliards de dollars on espère qu'il va
durer longtemps et qui va fonctionner
mais mais en revanche il durera on est
sûr qu'il y aura pas aussi longtemps que
bubble Hubble il était lancé en 91 il
fonctionne toujours 30 plus 31 ans après
il marche de manière merveilleuse encore
et en fait mais ça a été rendu possible
parce qu'il était en orbite autour de la
Terre et qu'il a pu être réparé par des
missions en navette spatiale là le James
web il est trop loin
effectivement ça va être ça va être plus
compliqué pour ce télescope qui est
quand même qui a coûté très cher on le
disait qui sait qui a payé c'est parce
qu'on a parlé de Joe Biden qui a annoncé
qui a donné la notion d'avant est-ce que
c'est parce que c'est lui qui a quand
même financé c'est une collaboration
internationale mais le gros gros du
financement ces États-Unis c'est la NASA
sur les 11 milliards il y en a 10 qui
ont été payés par les contribuables
américains en fait au début le télescope
il devait écouter un milliard quand il
était conçu le milliard de dollars et
l'Europe a dit nous notre contribution
ça sera on participe un petit peu à
quelques instruments comme Miry on en
parlait et on fournit le lancement donc
on vous donne une fusée arène 5 pour
lancer une fusil 5 ça coûte moins de 200
millions d'euros donc la contribution
européenne on a une participation au
projet avec du temps d'observation
parce qu'on a dit au début on participe
en donnant le lancement mais au final
comme le coup a explosé parce que les
Américains ont pas réussi à le
construire ils avaient trop de tests et
c'est le coup à exploser pour les
Américains le surco a été pris pour oui
c'est les Américains qui ont pris le
surcoût
pourcentage de c'est pas complètement
vrai le
pour les pour les Européens il y a eu le
le temps de développement très long a
quand même coûté cher parce qu'il y a
des gens qui ont travaillé pendant des
années sur ce télescope alors qu'il
devait il devait partir
première date de lancement c'était 2010
ou 2011 donc on est parti 10 ans après
donc toutes ces années de retard c'est
les gens qui continuent à travailler
donc des salaires et qui a eu il y a eu
aussi un surcoût pour l'Europe mais pas
du tout à la mesure de ce que ça a été
pour les États-Unis pendant pendant 10
ans
tous les autres programmes d'astronomie
aux États-Unis ont été figés bloqués
parce que il fallait financer le James
web il y a justement un article dans Le
Figaro ce matin qui dit que il y avait
beaucoup de critiques on se demandait si
ça valait le coup et tout
aujourd'hui ça a été balayé aujourd'hui
je pense qu'il y a plus personne qui
c'est vrai qu'il y a 10 ans il y avait
des astronomes qui disaient ça coûte
trop cher c'est on est pas sûr de savoir
le faire
ça de pas fonctionner le miroir est-ce
qu'il va bien se déployer les boucliers
fait que tout ça se déploiement se
déroule de manière parfaite il y a des
gens qui disaient on n'est pas capable
de le faire c'est trop compliqué il faut
arrêter et
donc le seul programme a été sauvé aussi
parce qu'il y a eu la NASA a mis des des
gens hyper compétents pour gérer le
programme et le sortir de son il était
en bourbé dans des difficultés
techniques et voilà mais quelle est
l'agenda maintenant pour ce pour ce pour
ce télescope est-ce qu'on sait quand
est-ce qu'on recevra de nouvelles images
et bien là en fait les observations
elles commencent les observations
scientifiques elles commencent jusqu'à
hier en étant dans la phase de ce qu'on
appelle de commissionnement de de mise
en service des instruments donc on
vérifie que tous les instruments
fonctionnaient parfaitement donc cette
phase est terminée
et donc les ingénieurs et les
techniciens et maintenant ils vont le
tout le télescope tout le temps de
télescope a servir les observations
scientifiques et donc depuis plusieurs
années il y avait des milliers de
milliers d'astronomes du monde entier
qui ont fait des propositions pour les
observations et il y en a quelques-uns
qui ont été retenus qui ont eu de la
chance et
comme comme les observations des
planètes trappistes les planètes
rocheuses et donc les enfants là ça y
est elle commence et les résultats vont
arriver avec dans les dans les semaines
qui viennent enfin déjà déjà la première
image là qu'on a vu avec les galaxies
lointaines
rien que cette image cette seule image
on estime qu'il y a plusieurs mois de
travail pour en extraire toutes les
données possibles donc et c'est une
seule image
de la lumière par la masse déterminer la
masse de cet amas de manière très
précise enfin qu'est-ce qu'on pouvait
pas faire avant
12 heures de photos pour 3 ans de
travail mais presque mais presque donc
en fait le les données vont arriver de
manière très rapide une grande partie
d'entre elles le seront disponibles à
communiquer internationale sans sans
barrière c'est-à-dire qu'elles sont
libre d'accès pour tous ceux qui veulent
les analyser donc ça va être une une
moisson de on va voir dans les mois qui
viennent des découvertes des annonces
des ça va ça va être fantastique donc en
fait il faut s'habituer à voir ce genre
d'image et avoir des avoir beaucoup de
d'image aussi magnifique que ça et
j'espère qu'on s'habituerait pas et
qu'on restera et on restera ébloui par
la merci en tout cas Cyril comme vous
avez compris on aurait pu rester ici
pendant des heures pour en parler parce
que c'était vraiment vertigineux
incroyable merci à vous en tout cas
d'avoir été très nombreux avec nous
merci Cyril d'avoir été merci Vincent
d'avoir été avec nous vous n'hésitez pas
à vous abonner à mettre un petit pouce
bleu sur la vidéo elle sera disponible
en replay comme d'habitude bien
évidemment et je vous dis à bientôt pour
de nouvelles et en plus quand il y aura
des nouvelles découvertes je pense qu'on
aura quelqu'un pourra parler en plus
très volontiers super merci beaucoup
Cyril à bientôt pour de nouveaux live
sur Figaro live